a thousand blades
taken from the hands of aegon's fallen
enemies forged in the fiery breath of
valerian the dread
there aren't a thousand blades
there aren't even two hundred i've
counted
ha i'm sure you have ugly old thing
yet it has a certain appeal
the lice are aaron of chairs shame you
had to settle for your second choice
early days my friend it is flattering
really you
feeling such dread at the prospect of me
getting what i want thoughting you has
never been my primary ambition i promise
you
although who doesn't like to see their
friends fail now and then you're so
right
for instance when i thought of your plan
to give sansa stark to the terrell's
if i'm going to be honest i did feel an
unmistakable sense of
enjoyment there
but you're confident the one who fed you
information about my plans the one you
swore to protect
you didn't bring her any enjoyment
and she didn't bring me any enjoyment
she was a bad investment on my part
luckily i have a friend
who wants to try something new
something daring
[Music]
and he was so grateful to me for
providing this
fresh experience
i did what i did for the good of the
realm
the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agree to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
but what do we have left once we abandon
the lie
chaos a gaping pit waiting to swallow us
all
chaos isn't a pit
chaos is a ladder
you